je suis en désaccord avec la une de
charlie hebdo quand elle humilie par la
satire le musulmans les chrétiens et les
juifs mais c'est pas parce que je suis
en désaccord que je me permet
d'interdire le droit de charlie hebdo à
blasphémer parce que je suis français
nous sommes dans un pays qui s'appelle
la france et qui a des règles qu'une
histoire qu'un culture donc le droit de
walsh ne blasphémer est un droit dans
notre pays si je ne suis pas satisfait
avec ce droit d'alors effectivement de
que je me mets en désaccord avec ce à
quoi on a droit dans la législation de
mon pays de que je suis profondément
profondément attaché à la liberté
d'expression
c'est vrai que lorsque celle-ci pertes
peine humilient je lui ai déjà dit nous
avions fait un débat dans balances ton
poste dès que l'année dernière et
j'avais dit effectivement que je ne me
reconnaissais pas et que je préférais
détourner le regard
parce que ça ne me plaisait pas et je
crois que je ne suis pas seul à
détourner le regard de line de charlie
hebdo et ils sont très nombreux
la preuve en est charlie hebdo cela a
été dit ne fonctionnait pas ne se
vendait pas alors après c'est parce que
ça ne fonctionne pas et que ça ne se
vend pas que je veux me permettre d'être
pour l'interdiction la ceinture je suis
en désaccord avec charlie hebdo mais je
le ils ont ce droit qui n'est pas permis
par mois par vous par la manière de
fonctionner par les règles parle là la
démocratie future de notre pays par la
notion de démocratie que notre pays
effectivement entretien à diffuser cette
une
mais en revanche je refuse d'être
enfermés entre elles me choque ou je les
admire si ni l'un ni l'autre je n'irai
le courage et à quelque chose
d'admirable non ça c'est toi qui
attribue du courage quelle moi je dirais
que se donne 24 heures dans leur petit
va aussi moi je veux aussi peu aussi
pour certains d'entre nous ait rappelé
de la provocation
or moi je considère aujourd'hui c'est
devenu leur vie ils ont ce droit de
convoquer la compresse que ce droit moi
est ce qu'il me plais est ce que je suis
en phase avec est ce que je suis en
accord avec la réponse est non et pas
simplement parce que je suis musulman et
ça parle des musulmans parce que ça
parle de mes amis catholiques ou
chrétiens je suis aussi choqués que ton
art
rt quand ça concerne les juifs je suis
aussi heurter parce que j'ai pas en bi
effectivement qu'on use et on abuse
effectivement dans la volonté de heurter
ou de penne
vendre du papier je pence que charlie
hebdo peut faire mieux ils ont décidé de
faire ça c'est leur problème je détourne
le regard c'est leur droit
je suis pas choqué parce qu'ils l'ont
fait parce que ce qui me choque le plus
c'est les morts liées au terrorisme
c'est que là je pense que c'est ça qui
doit aussi nous unir ces sept cette
abjection 7 à la barbarie de queue en
revanche on peut ne pas être d'accord et
charlie hebdo et charles et d'eau la
sonde doit être rangé dans le cas d'un
terreau quand ça se serait tenue de
route et ça fait des dizaines d'années
que hara kiri et charlie hebdo fond dans
ce registre là on le découvre
aujourd'hui pas du tout à fait de bien
sûr qu'il ya eu d une on peut aller en
désaccord depuis des dizaines d'années
temps qu'il faut mais aujourd'hui tout
ce qui était incroyable
eric ça c'est plutôt modérée par rapport
à ce qu'ils avaient les vivats